any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic get
started i'm here today with tom billio
who's been an influence on me tom you
didn't know this but i gave a tedx talk
back in 2014 along with her mutual
friend james altucher and he was the
closing actor i was the opening act and
i had to drop you know five pounds and i
didn't know how to do it because i'm
like addicted to eating you know sweets
and good tasting stuff and my trainer
friends told me gotta get this quest
nutrition it's like the real deal it
tastes just like a candy bar tastes like
a cookie i want to thank you
because of you you allowed me to drop
those five pounds i dropped them from my
double chin to my rear end and i just
there you go no seriously it counts you
did you really helped my life and i made
the ted talk i cut weight those five
pounds have made a big difference i want
to thank you for that that's cool man my
pleasure yeah when we started so i come
from a morbidly obese family so you know
that was at least for me that was the
whole idea was giving food that people
could choose based on taste and it
happened to be good for them yeah but
you didn't have to ask them to go out of
their way it was like we really wanted
it to taste like cookies candy pie you
know that kind of stuff yeah and the
ultimate goal the ultimate validation of
is my kids will eat that rather than you
know something or something like that
yeah we used to have a lot of people
report that which is tough yeah so i
wanted to start with uh actually going
further in that in that vein um you know
i heard interviews with you from years
back just about that process or what
your intent was not in the chemical you
know laboratories and the particle
accelerators uh et cetera et cetera but
to make something healthy to make
something that had uh mimic certain
properties that were delicious because
that is the best way to incentivize good
behavior i viewed that as very
scientific quest no pun intended i want
to talk about like the scientific method
how you approach things analytically and
what your rubric is how do you make
decisions like this like we're going to
get into this then we're going to pivot
we're going to become entertainment uh
then we're gonna pivot and we're gonna
get into nfts founders keys stuff like
that we'll get into how do you know when
you can make a pivot is there a rubric
is there a checklist how do you how do
you go through these yeah so it's
interesting so i created this thing
called the physics of progress you're
the right person to have this
conversation
and
so because i won i'm trying to navigate
my own life so i never would have
stepped in front of the camera if i
wasn't running businesses because for me
that's like i need to be checking that
this stuff really works i need to be
using it on a daily basis and then i'll
look into a camera and say here's what
i'm doing and these are the results
and
finding the like to try to explain to
somebody how you get good at business
because i'd often say things like
hey fill your heart with love think of
the community and all that but oh by the
way you also have to be business savvy
because there's a bunch of people out
there that have good intentions but they
can't grow a company yeah so i was like
what is
business savvy like you know how do you
explain that and
so i start breaking this down okay what
do i do and i'm like
all right well i start with my goal i
know what i'm trying to do and then once
i have my goal i just identify
i'm here and my goal is there and what
stands between me and that is
essentially entropy everything's moving
towards chaos so i have to inject all
this energy into this closed system in
order to create order but you have to do
it like a really specific way and that
specific way is understanding
the obstacle that stands between you and
where you want to go and then you
basically create a test like you have a
hypothesis and then a test you're going
to run to see if it works you run it you
learn and then you repeat and so i i
break this whole thing down and i'm like
it's the physics of progress and one of
the guys on my team was like that's the
scientific method yeah and i was like
what
he's like look it up so i look it up i'm
like oh my god this is literally the
scientific method recontextualized for
business
and what i love and you know people talk
about this in science a lot
when people rediscover the same thing
from different angles you know you're on
to something fundamental
and
truly everything has a physics of right
there's a point at which you're no
longer at analogy you're at first
principles and you're just thinking from
there and so business is no different
you need to get down to what is the
actual nature of the problem that you
face
and when you get to the nature of the
problem then you can build up so i do
this thing called business decision
making where people that have you know
thriving businesses come and it's like
give me your hardest problem and you'll
see without me knowing your industry i
can help you find the answer very
quickly because you're just you're
getting the first principles what's your
goal where are you what what is the you
know thing creating the problem and then
how do we come up with our best guess
hypothesis on the most efficient way to
solve that problem and then if we've
thought through that well we run that we
will fail to some degree and then we try
again and so it's what's really
interesting about that process is people
think that it's going to be complicated
they think what they need is my 20 years
of business what they actually need is
first principles thinking
and the second you get the first
principles you can now solve these it's
iterative of course but you can now
solve the problem do you think it can
work in reverse almost because of the
curse of knowledge like i mentioned
before we started filming you know that
most of my friends that teach economics
or teach at business schools or whatever
they're not super successful financially
not that that's the only metric for
surprising success obviously they're
incredibly intellectual but you know
most people that win the nobel prize in
economics for example they're not you
know billionaires right they're not uh
in practical terms and you would think
they know the the base layer as you call
it the zeroth first principles they know
that better than anybody is there such a
thing that's holding them back perhaps
this curse of knowledge like they know
it but they can't teach it because
they're too far away from being at the
beginner's mind perspective or that's
really interesting i so we could rabbit
hole on keeping a beginner's mind which
is more important than people realize
and and i think is the reason that
generations end up thinking they're at
war with each other they're not actually
at war it's just that people tend to
calcify into dogma and so it's
open-minded versus like calcified and
then that's why this generation then
will calcify and the next generation
will be open-minded but it's really if
you can keep an open mind i don't think
you find the conflict between the
generations
um but getting into why those people
aren't successful specifically
one is they're following their passion
and so they're super into something
they're in this feedback loop that to me
is very much like love love is only what
i'll call real love when it's
reciprocated so you get into a feedback
loop where i feel this thing you feel
that thing you flywheel yeah and it's
like oh my god you're making me feel
better i'm making you feel better and ah
like you get in this really cool loop
if you're developing a skill
and you're getting good at it and let's
say that they're in intellectual circles
or they're teaching or whatever and so
they get into that flywheel around the
education portion so they're actually
getting good at is teaching that thing
versus doing that thing now they could
flip it and decide i'm gonna go get good
at that thing instead of getting good at
teaching it
but what you'll find is there are
certain personality types
or personality elements that are
necessary to be successful in business
and the one that takes everybody by
surprise you must be able to self-soothe
and if you can't self-soothe you'll
never win as an entrepreneur because
you're thrown into an environment not
only is the market full of chaos but the
amount that you can do as one person is
so tiny that now you've got to get a
whole large group of people
to galvanize around an idea and a
direction
get all of them pointed in the same way
and moving at speed
then it's all going to break down
because one day somebody's dog is going
to been hit by a car that day their kid
is having a fit it's going to happen
cove it happens and so now so you're
like wait all i wanna do is economics
like i when i read the books i'm i'm on
fire i feel the way that i wanna feel
but when i'm dealing with hr i don't
feel the way that i wanna feel and so
they a thousand little moments like that
led them to just they kept hitting a
barrier and finding oh when i'm teaching
it when i'm reading about it when i'm
studying it when i'm alone with the idea
i'm in the loop that i want to be in and
then when i try to organize other people
and
like even dealing with the
administration or maybe they don't even
understand business where they have
like some people have conflicted ideas
around business and so
it's just enough of those little nudges
away from one side and towards another
that they get really good at one thing
and it doesn't monetize well right
yeah and if you look at it you know i
know you've talked a lot about this in
in the past but you know kind of the
inspiration the cynic simon since you're
finding your why or whatever
you know it's easy to optimize for that
in economic terms with money or in
influence and science we have citation
counts that's our metric that's our lucr
what what is to you
uh the the purpose of wealth because
obviously you're you know you're
optimizing to for financial success but
for impact as well
what is the the purpose of this i've had
con billionaires on i've been fortunate
to have billionaires on the podcast
everyone gives a different answer which
is not the same as like a scientist you
get five cents i wanna understand how
quarks work i want to understand how the
cosmos came to be i understand you know
the dna replication
but what is the purpose of wealth at
least as you see it tom
to me is all about what are you trying
to build so
i
very fortunately learned truly in a
visceral sense that money can't buy
happiness very early and i'll make that
more specific money doesn't influence
your neurochemistry the way that you
want it to
so what happens is at least if you grow
up like i grew up sort of middle to
lower middle class you looked at wealthy
people especially in the 80s when it was
like that was celebrated and amazing
and every john hughes film was set in a
neighborhood in chicago that i wanted to
live in
and you know i looked at that and
thought they were cool and amazing and
it was everything that i ever wanted and
you know so i had this sense of like
they're cool
i'm sort of lame i want to be that and
so if i get rich i will feel about
myself the way that i feel about them
now
and money can't do that so money won't
help you so whatever
insecurity you have whatever thing about
yourself that you don't like all of
that's going to follow you
and so i can make you as rich as humanly
possible and it it can't touch that part
and unfortunately i mean maybe
fortunately in fact fortunately
the only thing that really matters in
life is how you feel about yourself when
you're by yourself and you don't need to
be wealthy to feel good about who you
are and there's a whole formula that i
have for that
but
when i think about then why then do
people keep chasing money because even
i'm still chasing money and if i know
that that's not true and i've spent a
whole lot of energy in my life making
sure that i do feel good about myself
when i'm by myself
then why do things with revenue in mind
and the answer is because it lets you
build
and
if it is true that money at its very
nature and this is an idea i'm obsessed
with don't think about things think
about the nature of things once you
start thinking about what the nature of
money is now you understand why people
chase it so it's not going to help you
feel better about yourself but
it is a way to
basically capture your time and energy
and carry it across time without
devaluing it
and so now it's like whoa you're saying
that right now i can spend my time in a
way that's that can result in something
that i can take with me across time and
space
there's that's the only thing that you
can do that carries forward like that
every other use of your time it
terminates then and there maybe you have
a memory like if it's an experience or
something like that and that's useful to
be sure but even those tend to degrade
over time whereas if you can get good at
investing in a way that the economics
are captured and preserved what's really
being captured is the time and the
energy and so now you can essentially
aggregate
all that fruitful time and energy and
now you can point it at something and
the reason that matters is when you take
diffuse energy right i have however much
time i have left in my life but it's
sort of evenly spread out the energy
that i can use
but if i can capture it in the form of
money
now i've got a magnifying glass and now
i can build something i can aim that
magnifying glass and actually change the
world and so you think of a magnifying
glass turns this diffuse you know
radiation from the sun into something
entropy exactly and it will light [ __ ]
on fire
and so that's exactly what people can do
with their time and energy by turning
into money first
then you can concentrate it and you can
create something absolutely spectacular
and so once people understand that's the
nature of money that's the nature of
work now you don't expect it to be
something that it's not which is it's
not going to make me feel better about
myself but it is going to allow me to
build something so if i can build
something that makes me feel better
about myself now you get into this loop
so like my mission is to make sure that
nobody gets to the age of 15 without
encountering a growth mindset makes me
feel like i matter gives me meaning and
purpose but i need money to do it and so
i've been very thoughtful in my life
about doing things that allow me to
capture that energy i want to ask you
and feel free you know we can always cut
this out but you made a conscious
decision if i remember correctly not to
have children and i always say you know
people are greedy because they want to
teleport they want to live forever and
they want to take their money with them
they want to take their houses with them
and i said you can teleport tom you can
actually there's a physicist telling you
you can teleport you just can't go in
other words you can teleport your values
your mindset your philosophy even your
you know even your dna if that matters
to you and i'm less of a fan of like how
important dna and blood matters but with
a child and uh you know i'm blessed to
have children i feel like by the way
yeah right
but i'm blessed to uh to at least make
this teleportation of me and my wife and
our values into the future and i'm
curious and again it's not something you
want to talk about we can cut it out no
i love it let's [ __ ] go ask you the
hard questions i'm about i feel like you
you have so much impact on so many
people around the world but you know
there is a difference and i don't just
mean biological kids and some people
can't have kids you know a lot
ideological kids you're making a lot of
what was that choice like why was it
consciously uh done in a way that you
know i feel like if you have a stake in
the future as you do clearly um
oftentimes you want to incentivize that
by by your own children or by
ideological children so what why was
that i don't mean to ask you know prior
or anything but why was it a conscious
decision not to have children as as i
understand unless i'm oh no no you're
right on the money and i'm so not
sensitive because i see you can ask
so the way that i see it is this
i really
want kids like i really want kids i
could write you a poem about the the
transformational nature of that
um that would
convince you that i had kids because i
really understand what that's about
partly because i big brother for a kid
for eight and a half years and i see how
they become like
this thing that you care about and you
love and you want to protect and so like
i get it um
the only thing i want more than i want
to have kids
is to not have kids
and so it was this like ah man of
do i
because i i will regret not having
children when i'm old like i'm so aware
of that and so my thing is go into every
decision with your eyes wide open
understand everything is a trade-off so
um thomas soul i think is a brilliant
economist and he says there's no utopia
people no freelance there is just
trade-offs that's right and so to have
children would be this beautiful
trade-off and i would get something
absolutely extraordinary in terms of the
upside
but the life that i've worked so hard to
construct for myself is so joyful and
full of fulfillment
that i was like i'm trading unknown for
an unknown and it may be better and i
may do it and go oh my god of course
like how could i have ever
thought that i didn't want to do this
and i got a piece of advice and it
really and i remember when he said it to
me i said this is the best advice i'm
ever going to get on having kids
entrepreneur a successful guy and i was
really debating it i was like look i
love building so much i don't want
anything to pull me away from that and
i'm like really concerned yeah so what
do i do have kids not have kids he goes
tom
have kids don't have kids it doesn't
matter but whatever you do do it all the
way
and i was like whoa that is really good
advice and so i just decided that i
wanted to i never wanted to have
something that made me feel guilty that
i was at work
and i thought i already know like i have
two little dogs and if i work too much i
start feeling bad because of the dogs
and i just know myself well enough i
feel a tremendous sense of obligation to
help and to do better and if i have kids
i wouldn't be able to build the business
the way that i want to and that's a
trade-off and i will miss out on a huge
part of the human experience by making
that choice but i also capture something
that people with kids won't be able to
do which is to be unconflicted about
that thing that you're doing and that
there is nothing because i built i'm
building the company with my wife so
it's like the more i invest in my
marriage the more i can invest in the
company and i don't have anything that's
you know sort of calling me or wanting
me home
and to make matters worse i'm very close
with my extended family so all of that
sense of
connection and camaraderie and love and
joy that comes from the familial
environment
i get from them
but as they die off i really am going to
say [ __ ] i gave up a lot to do all of
those things and
in that and i've tried to run the
thought experiment of whether it will be
cold comfort to me
that i have built these things and all
of that
and i come to one inescapable truth
about the human condition the only thing
that matters is your frame of reference
and so if in that moment i say
you sacrificed like an idiot
you gave up you could have children at
your bedside right now taking care of
you loving you and you sold that out for
what for a company
to help strangers halfway around the
world for money
i'm disgusted what were you thinking and
if that's my frame of reference it will
be devastating emotionally and i will be
ruined
but what i know is that i don't need to
choose that frame of reference and the
other frame of reference is to say
you built something that mattered and it
impacted people's lives and you
optimized for joy while you were doing
it that the pursuit of that thing gave
you so much that there were days where
you were giddy looking around like i
this fight that i'm doing to build this
company win or lose has been the most
fun i've ever had in my life
and
you really tried to maximize your
potential and to be fulfilled to matter
to do things that help and that was
awesome and so if now you wish that you
had had kids mourn that do whatever you
need but don't lose sight of what you
were really doing and what the frame of
reference was that got you here and i
find any decision in your life you can
just flip your frame of reference it's
the same truth but you look at it from
one angle and it feels terrible you look
at it from another angle and suddenly
you're like wow that actually feels
amazing
um so i will be i am very thoughtful
about how i frame right the things in my
life especially the things i can't
change it wasn't just you know oh we are
frivolous and we won't be able to take
as many trips to europe that's certainly
true although not too many people are
you know taking world trips right now
right um so what do you think is the
most misunderstood
thing about either you or business and
there's there are concepts that are
misunderstood by the general public
entropy we talked about that maybe we'll
talk a little bit more i mean one of my
favorite things to think about is if i
ask you tom like how can i make your
life twice as good right now like if i
give you you know twice as much money
does it make your life twice as good not
really i mean going water ski behind one
yacht at a time right that's how i spend
my money but yes because i go
immediately to how much faster could i
build and would that really help um but
yeah so then if i ask you you know how
can i make your life half as good there
are infinite number of ways right
especially if you have very easy your
dog yeah whatever yeah with kids it's
even more so um so people kind of
neglect that optionality that there is
this network effect there is this
entropic you know dependency and there's
more availability of states that your
life could be worse then it could be
better that's really interesting and and
for that reason which is the definition
of entropy it's disorder to order and
then it's much harder to get ordered and
focusing the light like you said before
it's
organizing and the sun puts out a lot of
energy but it's not as well organized
until we use it on earth so i'll ask you
what is the most misunderstood part
about you your life the businesses that
you make what seems easy to people is
really hard what's really hard that
seems easy how do you um how do you like
parcel out because you only have uh you
know this limited resource of time
although i want to get into other
aspects that are limited in my opinion
but how do you how do you allocate
resources to direct them entropically to
focus into the sunlight beam of you know
laser intensity that you do so
exquisitely well
well so in terms of what do people
misunderstand i don't know i don't spend
a lot of time um
i just don't get that feedback it's not
like i'm doing some heroic thing to
avoid it or anything i just i haven't
got a lot of feedback but in terms of
what people misunderstand about business
it's really emotional regulation and so
i've seen a lot of people that were far
smarter than i um they either don't have
the stamina
or they can't
they can't deal with the emotional pain
of failure and because to learn you must
fail if you can't reorient yourself to
not worrying about that
you're never going to make it so that's
that's the part in business i'm always
trying to give people
about me that i'm trying to get people
to understand i am not smarter than the
average person i'm not a fast thinker i
am a
obsessive thinker so i end up thinking
deeply about things but i'm not a fast
thinker
but despite that i've been able to
put together a useful set of ideas and
skills that allow me to move forward
because i can emotionally regulate
myself
deal with failures and then let the
knowledge from the failures stack that's
like my real superpower
now how do i allocate the resources that
everything is goal driven like what is
your goal this is the thing that the
number of people that come up to me
usually as an entrepreneur and they're
like all right tom i'm really struggling
like what's the key and i'm like don't
say a word i'm going to make a
prediction
i'm going to ask you what your goal is
and you're going to tell me you know
exactly what it is then you're going to
say it out loud and it's going to be
really vague
and they're like no i got it
and so then i ask cool what's your goal
i want to win a gold medal and i'm like
amazing in what the olympics yes the
olympics fantastic summer or winter
summer great swimming or tennis swimming
fantastic backstroke freestyle medley
like what are we doing people think
they're clear because they have that
like initial sort of ballpark thing that
they want to do right yeah and the
answer people actually give when i say
okay what's your goal i want to help
people right
it's not a business right it's so big
so like you have to get laser targeted
what by when and how much yeah like when
you get that focused on what it is that
you're trying to do metrics yeah then we
can back into the next 15 minutes
because they're you know where you want
to be you know where you are and so if
you can get good at identifying that gap
the entropic principle the thing that's
the problem
then we can start figuring out what our
proposed solution is once we think we
know our proposed solution to the
problem that stands between us and our
goal now i know what to do in the next
15 minutes i know whether i need a
racket or a swimming pool
and until you get that kind of clarity
on what it is you need to become the
best in the world at in order to achieve
your goal
you can't move forward and so
allocating my energies is always around
first principles thinking around that
scientific loop that we talked about
knowing where i'm trying to get to
and i want to pivot a little bit uh
because i see you pivoting so much in
life and it's so commendable because i
think you know one of the lessons i've
gotten from interviewing 10 nobel prize
winners to date is that when they get
bored of something when they're not
having fun
that's the key moment that's the
question you know they say about
marriages if you if a psychologist is
interviewing someone you know a couple
and they're having a problem if one of
them like rolls their eyes or that
person they're going to get divorced
like it's just a 99 correlation when
you're not having fun as a scientist
which you normally don't think of
anything about you know very bookish in
studios
but it's actually really fun and it's
very creative which people don't often
appreciate as well um what is your
rubric again your metrics focus guy so
what what do you appreciate obviously
business has a metric it's built in but
i see your you know kind of killer you
know app or your secret power superpower
is actually your your podcast your
interviews the conversations that you
have the deep dives that you take both
you need to do a live and how you're
doing it here
what how do you know when you're doing
well as an interviewer like what what
like what is going on in your mind what
app because i know you've got an app
running in your background like i'm
doing good i'm doing better like i'm
sitting here you're telling me about the
you know optionality that you decide
with not having kids and i'm like that's
kind of giving me chills like that's
really cool at least he's thought about
he's not some selfish you know
self-absorbed guy but how do you know
when you're interviewing somebody like
give us like that app that's running in
your mind because you're obviously two
different interview styles so it partly
depends on which interview i'm running
if i'm doing the you just wrote a book
and i'm trying to help you give the best
interview you're ever going to give to
distill the book then it's like i map it
out beforehand and i'm like how close
are we getting to stringing together the
best answers they've ever given to these
questions into one like nice concise
package not like the first time they
ever told the secret but the best time
the best yeah so i i find their loop
and then i help distill their loop down
and then hopefully have tangents that i
want to go into that really clarify and
are fresh
and so that's interview style number one
interview style number two is that
they're on a topic that i'm so
fascinated by i know the interview is
going well when i completely forget that
i'm interviewing them and i'm just
locked in
and this was so about two years ago now
i pulled my team aside and i said look
i'm not having fun anymore
and i'm doing the same interview over
and over and over and it's not
interesting to me
and so we're going to need to broaden
the type of interview that i can do
and what was happening was i was
interviewing mindset people and it was
getting to the point where i could give
a better mindset interview than answer
than they could and so i was like this
isn't fun anymore
and
to expand it it was there needed to be
some
niche like what's gonna be that thing
and so the idea was okay well i'm
building a mindset so i can deploy it
against something and so now i'm going
to start bringing people on that i'm
just fascinated by that are you know
whether it's a neuroscientist or an
astrophysicist you know people that and
i'm like look the audience we didn't
build that audience right so it's going
to be a rough we're going to go through
the desert for a while
and we will come out the other side
because eventually we will gather a
different crowd
and but it was it was two years of like
ooh our growth has really slowed down
but now as it clicks over and you know
we built this other community it's like
we're demolishing our all-time records
and um just going crazy but you really
i mean to bring it back to your initial
question like you have to know
what you're trying to deliver to the
audience to know the metric by which to
judge it
and do you find that like things that
are seemed ancillary or maybe unrelated
you know i call it for you your forklift
moment things that you would have never
thought would come into play in a
business and then okay i know how to
drive a forklift and that's going to
save my ass one day but are there things
serendipitously that you kind of quote
unquote count on and that contributes to
your success or is it more methodical
because i see this paradox in you and
the methodology
methodical and also very very kind of
not carefree but just open to
serendipity yes and now i'm gonna say uh
it's not a quote but an idea that you'll
actually be able to tell me if this is
real because i've quoted this so many
times and every time i'm like i'm pretty
sure i remember this right
uh that most nobel prizes are awarded
where two areas overlap so it's like
chemistry and physics or whatever and so
like rosalind franklin discovered dna
she was a physicist they wanted for
medicine totally correct correct yeah
all right i'm very happy to hear that
that's real now that i think is the
reason i've been successful the way that
i have so synergy what yeah because what
ends up happening my perfect example is
so
almost every 10 years i've ended up
disrupting myself and moving into
something completely different so i
start in filmmaking then i go to
technology software security software of
all things then i go into nutrition
no software nothing to do with
filmmaking nothing and now into media so
at quest what helped was while i was a
filmmaker before and so i built out a
whole studio inside of a protein bar
company and
social media ends up becoming our thing
it wasn't even called social media back
then so it was like nobody was doing it
but because i was a filmmaker by trade
it made sense to me and so we were
creating content as a company before
other companies were doing it ends up
being one of the things that helps us
blow up
now you move into
media start a comic book division at
impact theory
go into it and as soon as i see the
distribution model i'm like wait i just
came from nutrition where we're
distributing to you know 90 000 points
of distribution i've got down to the
shelf like what's moving how many units
i have yeah i mean it's like you're
getting real-time data and because of
that i can do marketing in specific
regions and not others and i know what
flavors work where
and so it's like with that data i can
steer the company yes but in comics it's
like from the 90s i'm not kidding one
distributor it was a joke and so i'm
like
guys you can't do this and so we got on
a call with them and i'm like hey we
need this data this data this data and
they're like we're not going to supply
that so i'm like well then we're not
going to print comics anymore like it
was so self-evident i'm like looking
around to all the other comic
distributors i'm like guys you can't put
up with this like this is insane and so
we immediately pivoted hard to
going pure digital and so then literally
we hard pivot pure digital covet hits
now the comic world is like imploding
because none of them are digital we're
popping off because we've gone digital
and it's like i never would have moved
that quickly if i didn't have the
experience from being in
the um nutrition industry so it's like
you end up going whoa like this thing
that i never would have realized that
driving the forklift for people that
don't know that story
you know my dad forcing me to work in a
paint factory as a kid learning how to i
had to get certified to drive forklift
and angry at my dad like thinking this
is the dumbest thing ever i'm like why
are you making me do this
and but in the bill you household every
summer you had to have a job and so yeah
i ended up paint factories paint
warehouses because my dad works for a
paint company and then flash forward 15
17 maybe even 20 years later i don't
remember how long
and
the equipment shows up at quest and we
look around and we're like how are we
getting it off the semi like what what
have we done we've just taken delivery
of like
hundreds of thousands of dollars of
equipment and a big semi truck backs up
and there's no way to get it off the
truck and into the warehouse and my
partner's like looking around and oh my
god if only we knew how to drive
forklift and i'm like
guys i actually do know how to drive a
forklift and so went got the forklift
from a neighbor in the you know the
complex
unloaded everything and i literally
looked into a camera and was like dad
wax on wax off man it's crazy that's
awesome and so yeah skill acquisition is
the name of the game you never know when
you're going to need something look be
intentional about the skills that you
acquire but don't be afraid to reinvent
because it it does end up coming back in
some way you know going back to your
olympics analogy you know i feel like
the most successful people are like the
biathletes like they're not the best
skiers they're not the best shooters but
they're the best guys who can ski and
shoot at the same time and maximize that
vector that projection into into that
space um i want to pivot in the last few
minutes uh to my standard three
questions i ask all my guests but before
we do i want to talk about nfts because
you've obviously gotten really
interested in it first of all i remember
you saying like your goal is become
disney 2.0 3.0 whatever um now you're
obviously incredibly invested into the
invested you know in terms of your
intellectual capital uh into nfts and
and so forth those on the surface i mean
there's comics and so forth but those on
the surface don't appear to be
completely co-aligned if i'm your career
coach like can you explain to me how do
those dovetail together or do they have
not have to no they do dude okay so i'm
obsessed i hope we got a little bit of
time
i have a whole strategy
so when we started impact theory i said
to the team our job is to stay in
business long enough to find our moment
of disruption
and i didn't know what it was going to
be i could not have predicted that it
would end up being nfts but as an
entrepreneur you have to look for
cultural energy
and there's been something really weird
happening in the culture that i round to
and i don't know how you feel about
swearing on the show i've done it a
couple of times already so you can beep
it out that's what i call there's [ __ ]
you [ __ ] the man energy building up
and um you know i'm authoritarian yeah
like so i'm watching this and i'm like
oh there's something going on like
there's all this friction between the
generations like what is this
and i'm beginning to realize that you
when you look at tectonic plates there's
all this pressure building up oh my god
you actually know the person so
eric weinstein says yes somewhere i
don't remember where i heard i don't
think he said it to me but he said um
the generations
the part of the all this friction is
that the old generation isn't passing
the baton to the new generation remember
when you said it he is one of the
smartest people on the planet i sit at
his feet constantly but it's the one
thing he's ever said where i
no thought ever hands off the baton yeah
it's just that historically
physicality was such a part of our
day-to-day life that the old generation
couldn't hold on to power they were just
outperformed by young people but now
everything is becoming information and
therefore experience is more useful than
youth vigor and physical strategy wisdom
is more important than knowledge exactly
well said so they're able to cling to
power in a way that previous generations
couldn't and so you're getting all this
friction building up between the
generations
and
the housing bubble happens burst satoshi
writes a white paper creates [ __ ] you
man money
and so no one's ever gonna like lord
this over us again we understand this
decentralized movement and we're gonna
do this whole thing
and so here i am going okay i've got
this huge incumbent in disney that has
done an extraordinary job i am in
nothing but awe of my competition like
what they've done is absolutely
breathtaking
and i'm looking at it going okay they've
got a 90-year head start they've got
billions of dollars in ip and billions
of dollars in revenue how am i ever
going to brand yeah
exactly how am i ever gonna like really
have my moment
then i start looking at the blockchain i
see what's happening there somebody
introduces me to the idea of digital
scarcity like six years ago and i
remember seeing it going that's going to
change my business forever but then
probably forgot about it because the
tech wasn't there yet
and
um
as it you know goes people start
creating all this incredible
infrastructure and then about eight
months as of when we're recording this
ago somebody says the letters nft in a
string to me for the first time
and i within 72 hours have allocated
millions of dollars in capital because i
realize one thing that nfts does that
gives me what i need in order to
actually take on disney and that is
going back to that in fact the
magnifying analogy i got from thinking
about why nfts are changing the world
because it isn't that they're
collectibles that's cool and that's like
a part of what makes it work it's not
even the technology which the technology
is so important and to think from first
principles you have to understand it but
that technology allows for
companies now to really harness in an
efficient way the energy of a community
which has not yet been possible so what
it's opened is this ability all that
[ __ ] you to the man energy that's pent
up
you're able to take a distributed
mentality and say hey
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna create
products but i'm going to let you as the
community capture the long tail value of
that now the second that became
technologically possible for the
audience to capture 90 percent of the
long tail value of the products that
they helped promote you just changed
everything why because
the current incumbent companies will not
be able to make the mental switch this
is exactly how incumbents get disrupted
every time they calcify into dogma and
they end up getting disrupted by
somebody who just has come up in a new
world it's so fun having a scientist so
i can use all these quotes max planck
right yeah science does not advance one
inside at a time it advances one funeral
at a time
why because people cannot let go of
these ideas that worked they worked you
built a career on them kodak did great
right but you can't do it when you see
the digital camera even though you
invented it right so it becomes this
whole quagmire so now you get a company
like me all i'm looking for is a moment
of disruption and you're telling me all
i have to do is give up a ton of revenue
no problem because
what i actually need is the magnifying
glass
i don't actually need that much revenue
it's very easy to give that away in the
short term because it comes back in the
long term
so imagine i'm not trying to build the
next netflix right now that's a
distribution platform oh god the thought
of trying to build that no way like
that's
unimaginable amounts of capital to try
and build
not going to do that
but i can build something on the back of
nfts that allows me to just get my
community absolutely fever pitched
because they know so we have a product
coming up called merry mods it's a story
we want to turn it into a franchise but
we're making an nft of it first which
they can then buy and then if i actually
pull off turning that into
uh you know a franchise that collectible
ends up having real value and so
you create an incentive in the audience
because they're going to on the
secondary market will take a very small
amount they'll capture
the absolute lion's share of that
and
now
if i go to netflix netflix and say hey
guys all you holders of the merry mods
project
we're going to be pitching netflix i
want you to stand in the parking lot
with a sign that says all watch merry
mods right and if i can get and that's a
bit tongue-in-cheek but if i can get 5
000 people to activate to show up to
call in to whatever
then
it's a very different negotiation and so
i learned an immutable truth at quest
which is whoever's closest to the
audience controls the negotiation
and if you've added value to the
audience's life and then ask them to do
something that's sort of low effort for
them but huge impact for you yes they'll
do it it's absolutely incredible and the
blockchain is what unlocks my ability to
capture that energy by giving them
products that they capture the value of
and it's just like i say this to as many
entrepreneurs as i can as fast as i can
about how they've got to switch the way
they think you need an nft strategy this
is about
activating your community and letting
them
participate in the growth of the
companies and products that they help
support it's never existed before so i
want to you know start to wrap up with
that concept but now apply to science my
domain so it used to be that you know
professors would get you know decent
salaries that made them a public you
know employee of the state of california
but i have freedom i had academic
freedom uh i had none of the kind of i
had all the upside in the past but none
of the administrative bureaucratic uh
you know all the different hurdles and
sort of legal compliance that i have to
go through every single day that i have
almost no time to teach by the way they
never taught me how to teach how to
learn that myself on my own and then uh
but also there i'm expected to do
research and i'm not making as much
money as i could and i see my students
that go to google and apple and and come
here or something like that they're
making twice the salary of a public
employee so i'm asking you know on
behalf of other scientists is there a
strategy or you know where you could see
it from the creator side you talked
about from the from the broader platform
side of how they could be participant
beneficiary owners of this intellectual
property but somebody has to create now
in science you know you'd like to think
oh science belongs to the public
and it does if the public pays your your
salary pays for my research grants pays
for my graduate students but what if
they don't i i guess i worry about a
slightly dystopian phenomenon and i'm
hoping that you'll disabuse me of that
notion which is that if we nftis you
know andrew huberman who was on your
podcast recently saying this is great
you know we're going to look for you
know first microscope picture of this
you know this gene
i i actually found it very scary because
privatizing science is antithetical to
what i think of a science i actually
find that very frightening um and so i'm
worried that could we become a victim of
the success and the scalability that you
evangelize so successfully if nfts go
into science in other words i get the
case for business for-profit or whatever
science i would like to think is for the
public but along those lines we also you
know don't do a great job selling it to
the public i mean a scientist they say
is outgoing if he looks at your shoes
when he talks to you right
so we're not we have a great
we have a great script and we're
terrible actors that's amazing are you
worried about and you know kind of like
ice nine phenomena where it's just going
to go across the world and that's a
great reference yeah so so i did not so
i will just abuse you you're going to
see a wonderful future look let's always
remember thomas soul is correct
everything is a trade-off right but uh
here's how it will actually play out so
the big concern the sort of irony of
ironies the big criticism of nfts is why
would i ever pay money for something
that's available to everybody
so they're gonna remain available to
everybody for a couple reasons one it's
the same reason when somebody buys art
the vast majority of people want to put
it somewhere people can see it
and the adoption of art in nfts is
a hundred times a thousand times more
than art that's gonna hang in your house
why because you can flex it
now there is a there's this idea of the
god neuron right that some people just
have a neuron in their brain that makes
them
much more
responsive to religious experience
and so they have this sense of awe and
wonder and so they can't fathom how
somebody could not believe in god
i think there's also what i'll call an
ownership neuron where there are just
some people they just want to own it
even if it's a star in the sky and
everyone gets to look at it that's true
to them it just matters it means
something to own now i happen to have
that neuron so i'm like yo that's mine i
own it that's in my wallet right now
there's a whole side to
nfts where there's the way up to think
of nfts it's nfts with matrix code
hiding inside of it right it's not like
putting it in a free portal in the
bahamas
can't see the code but it's there yeah
and so i can imbue it with utility yeah
so it isn't just that oh you are the
like i saw this meme that was like oh i
get nfts now if i own it i'm the only
one that's allowed to pretend that i
actually own it
and
when you don't understand metadata
that's what it seems like but for
instance we did a project called the
impact theory founders key if you have
one of the keys anybody could go screen
grab it and now they have your exact
pixel perfect copy of your key but if
you show up to one of my live events and
try to get in i'm gonna scan it and i'm
gonna see that you don't have metadata
and then it's not actually yours
so it's imbued with a intelligent
feature that right absolutely is not not
repeatable not replaceable not not
breakable yeah exactly so what i think
is going to happen in science it will be
something like this is the first photo
of you know whatever gene whatever
breakthrough star
of a nebula or whatever and the people
that want to own it are now going to be
able to own it and then when it's a real
moment like that becomes culturally
significant think about uh nba top shot
so nba top shots done hundreds of
millions of dollars in revenue selling
moments that just the night before were
free right anybody can watch tape it
anybody can watch now go on youtube and
see it yeah but people still want to own
it right and so now when science finally
has this moment where somebody like you
or huberman or whoever can say hey
public here is this new discovery for
everybody to see look at it take it
and by the way we've got the nft right
now
they're more incentivized than ever to
make sure that the whole world knows
about that why because it makes the nft
more valuable so now the more famous
they can make the information the more
famous they can say this moment really
matters it leads to this and look people
go take the information and people like
oh my god this leads to this
breakthrough that breakthrough ah it's
all this stuff is happening because this
person shared it with the world that nft
skyrockets in value in a community that
cares about science and cares about nfts
when i say that
over the next whatever 20 years billions
of dollars will be generated i mean
billions of dollars
3.8 billion dollars were generated in
nfts in august of 2021 alone
so i'll say over the next 20 25 years
there will be billions of dollars in
educational scientific things that
people are going to create in nfts that
the market will say this was a
relevant enough moment and a scarce
enough supply that this matters
and then
most of that value will be transacted on
the secondary market so the community
gets to capture that value we talked
about how important that is
but you can get to the benefit of the
creation right for several reasons one
they'll get a royalty if they're smart
they don't have to but that will
certainly help fund more science and all
of that
but also they become known as the person
that did that the nft matters they
become sort of celebrities within that
culture which gives some more attention
and trust me attention opens doors and
it just becomes this incredible loop
yeah yeah and the last thing i'll say
about that i also think there's a
parallel kind of metaverse with
blockchain in general that you could
have things which are scarce in science
like proof of discovery proof you know i
discovered that the universe is
expanding and accelerating rate well
that's pretty darn cool but i'm not
ready i have to validate it verify it
but if somebody else if i submit it to
peer review you know which is like the
ultimate centralized you know finance of
science then someone could steal that
block my paper i never get it published
they discover they claim discovery of it
right but if you have proof of actual
accomplishment proof of discovery
whatever you want to call it that could
revolutionize that's huge that's huge
once you timestamp it on the blockchain
that's it it's open and unverifiable
the next kind of stage in this in this
conversation um i want to just maybe
pivot to one last thing or revolving you
know crypto and so forth and that is you
know revolves around the three things
that are here one is a that's a piece of
gold this is a bookmark from my first
book i'm going to leave with you so this
is gold this is a meteorite this is 4.2
billion years old this is your gift wow
for coming on the into the impossible so
cool so that's 4 billion years old now
talk about proof of work okay so for
that to occur you had to have a
supernova explode in the local arm of
our galaxy imbuing the local arm that we
would later inhabit with dense metals to
make a core of the earth to crystallize
light metals and so forth to the
gravitational field not be too heavy
like jupiter and just have gas and suck
up ice and we can live there so for us
to be here that thing had to be there
and as a result of an explosion gold
comes from the collision of two neutron
stars talk about you know proof of work
that occurred you know billions of years
ago as well and then eventually migrated
its way to where our earth would form in
the solar system and is in the crust at
some level how do you and then i have
this book uh and i have a quest cookie
over here um and and these are sort of
uh you know fungible in some sense or
another but um
to the extent of convincing the ordinary
average person you know uh
of of the value of something that as you
say is replicatable is uh on the content
side when they see this there's only one
of those and i took a neutron star
explode you know for that to create it
how do you cause that that phase change
you know to use a physics term in in
just ordinary people to say like this
meta object you know which weighs
nothing can be transported you and i
both had a michael sailor on you know he
loves to wax exotically about you know
bitcoins travels at the speed of light
try doing that with gold or whatever um
but you know how do you convince people
of that uh you know when it's not in our
nature as human beings we like scarcity
our mind thrives on finite games of
collecting things like nobel prizes and
cookies and and gold how do you how do
you convince the average person to go
against maybe that is that genetic i
guess is what i'm getting to is there
something visceral in the human being
that maybe distrust the ephemeral the
digital the meta um or do you think
that's you know just a matter of time
and maybe i'm a little awesome yeah i
think it is literally only change
so
people have a hard time changing so if
you have come to value the physical if
you have the amazing frame of reference
that you have for explaining this is too
neutron stars colliding and that's the
only way that we get gold for you that's
so cool that it's like okay it's neat
that you can do like mathematically
sound money with computers but that
doesn't have the romance of the clients
but not everybody has the understanding
when you say neutron stars like yo you
know what that means right most people
are like i don't know what that is
that's like uh it's esoteric right
whereas
what they really respond to is just what
they grew up with so if you grew up and
your friends are like oh you know did
your parents give you any eath today are
you using your wallet to you know pick
up a new skin on fortnite
it just is it's you know david foster
wallace this is water for them it will
be self-evident that that's just a
superior it is the way that money is
handled right so the transitional
generation is the only generation that
like we really have to think about it
and so
yeah and so where it starts is can they
generate
enough
um
of a use case so that you want it and so
bitcoin
and ethereum as of the time of this
recording specifically have done a very
good job because you've got people like
me and trust me this is not financial
advice do your own research but like
when i look at my portfolio and i'm like
guys i'm making so much money this is
insane and all i did was listen to
somebody who said tom take an amount of
money that you're willing to lose and
put it in this and just see what happens
i finally did it once i actually
understood the technology and you just
see that number going up now it's
volatile so i've also seen it go down
but my thesis is to hold so i've seen
you look every day you talk about paul
about that right exactly and so i've
seen a lot more up than i've seen down
and
i mean now it gets into a very
complicated question why it has so much
value with inflation and all of that
sure um but
the transitional generation there will
be a fight and some people will say wow
this isn't really valuable and this is
dumb and look at all these people and
you already see that going on right now
but the use case of it is gets pretty
profound pretty fast and so people that
give it a try i think the overwhelming
number of them nothing will ever be 100
but the overwhelming number of people
that get in will be
rewarded either in just its frictionless
money yeah it's so easy right um like
literally today i had a vendor that i
owed 50 eath to it's a lot of money now
normally i'd have to like [ __ ] call
and deal with all the stuff to get the
money and like get it out and get all
their numbers and i'm panicking is this
right and i was literally like cool just
send me your um
your address and i'll send it to you
right now and so it gives me the address
this the address yes that's the address
no paypal click
and you know whatever 90 seconds later
he's got the payment wow so
it either is better or it isn't in ways
that people value and to the extent that
it is better in ways that people value
it will be adopted
um otherwise it won't be i'd love to
someday talk to you about you know how
do you steal man versus straw man
different approaches but in the limits
inches of time i want to ask you my
patented three rapid fire questions all
related really fast i want to give you
an answer to that because it's actually
really important yeah yeah so you have
to hunger to know why and where you're
wrong
and the only way that people will hunger
to know why and where they're wrong is
if they care more about their goal than
being right
and if they build their self-esteem
around finding the right answer rather
than being right right if you do that oh
my god then the world suddenly opens to
you so i'm desperate even though it
still hurts it's embarrassing when i'm
wrong and i've said something and
somebody's like that's actually not true
i'm like oh god but now i'm like cool
give it to me it hurts it stings but now
i can actually do something like you
said before it's like all growth is you
know involved some pain or whatever
right and one way or another yeah and
here's the phrase i want to like on my
tombs this is gonna be well let me fold
this in so arthur c clark 2001 in space
odyssey there are these monoliths that
are floating around they're like time
capsules that are going to last a
billion years what do you put on your
billion-year lasting time capsule you
ready yep plan on me
skills have utility
i just want people to understand
you learn something because it lets you
do something
and so if you protect your ego and you
never learn then you can't do
anything and so your entire life becomes
about managing your neurochemistry and
you never get to do anything or
experiencing anything but once you're
like i don't value myself for being
right i value myself for identifying the
right answer so i'm more than happy to
be wrong
in fact mistakes and failure are the
most information-rich data stream on
planet earth
so
i'm more than happy to do that
and in doing that and learning those
lessons i can now do things other people
can't do
and the most fun way to explain that is
the most talented athletes on planet
earth were paid millions of dollars to
stop kobe bryant from putting a ball in
a little hoop
and despite that he got so good that he
scored 81 points in a single game
against other pros yeah correct
and so it's like
if that doesn't get you excited to go
get so good at something that people
can't stop you like they actually can't
stop you not like i mean that is a
theoretical thing i mean literally yeah
they can't stop you like that's super
power yeah no i call that uh humble
humble swagger you know if you can
balance dichotomies of being having
appropriate humility but not being
cowardly the talmud says the easily
embarrassed cannot learn you can't learn
if you're easily embarrassed
you can't create greatness unless you
have a little bit of swagger second
thing so that came from arthur c clarke
the namesake of my uh
center for human imagination at ucsd
that i'm co-director of the first uh the
other question uh comment that usually
comes into play is uh he said arthur c
clarke said the only way of determining
the limits of the possible is to go
beyond them into the impossible that's
the title of my podcast i want to ask
you a kind of advice to your former self
what aspect of life perplexed you as a
20 year old 30 year old whatever
that you know could you give advice to
that person to give him the courage to
do as you've done to go into the
impossible what would that advice to
your former self be so the lesson i
needed to learn
is i was really worried that i wasn't
smart enough to be successful like that
haunted me in a way that no matter how i
try to explain it to people they won't
understand i'm talking almost being
paralyzed
with just like did you ever see the
movie amadeus yeah right so solieri in
was a real-life contemporary mozart and
he laments to god in the movie and he
says god why make me just good enough to
recognize that i'll never be as good as
mozart and i was like somebody sees me
that's what it's like to be me i feel
like i've been made just smart enough to
realize i'll never be
really smart like i'll never be one of
the greats
and that really bothered me and what i
ended up learning which is encapsulated
in a quote and i need to look back up
who said this because it's so good
you can't make a racehorse out of a pig
but you can make a really fast pig
and so my life is the answer to the
question what does a really fast pig
look like and so i would have told
myself stop worrying about whether or
not you're a racehorse just become a
fast pig it's so much better than where
you're at now like you will die you'll
run out of time long before you run out
of potential to realize so stop worrying
about whether
you're
one of the greatest and just get a
thousand times better right yeah there's
a famous story in the talmud that the
famous rabbi goes to heaven and says i
never became like moses and god's like
well moses didn't get into the promised
land and so you're not getting into your
own promised land either but i didn't
want you to be the next moses i wanted
you to be the best rabbi zusha that was
his name well tom bill you uh it's been
an honor uh getting to interview you
you've influenced my life personally
physically mentally and i know millions
around the world i just want to thank
you for your awesome mission that you've
been on may it continue as we say to 120
thank you tom thank you for having me
man this was so fun
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]